*Fait du beat box*
Comment allez-vous ?
Moi, ça va depuis que j'ai
réussi à faire ce mouve
Mes amis, on se retrouve aujourd'hui
pour la seconde et dernière partie du fan game
que Benjamin avait fait,
la première partie m'avait totalement fait kiffer,
la deuxième, ça va être tout aussi cool j'espère...
On s'était évanoui après un maximum d'épreuves difficiles
et nous avons spawn dans cette barque !
Voilà !
Alors, une cassette ...
Ah, Faut que j'aille choper la cassette
Je rappelle que c'est...
Ah faut pas que je touche l'eau
Interdit !
D'accord
Eh mec j'adore, dans la vraie vie j'adore faire ce jeu
Dans la vraie vie j'adore faire ce jeu des cailloux
J'pense que Ben aussi c'est pour ça qu'il l'a fait ingame
Ok
Y'a pas de save
Si je perd là
on chiale voilà
c'est tout ce qui se passe
TABERNAK
Ptain d'entrée de jeu il  nous la met dans le cul la
Ben hein direct !
excusez moi je suis vulgaire
Mais quand je rage je suis vulgaire
D'ailleurs quand je rage pas aussi je suis vulgaire
Je suis tout le temps vulgaire
Qu'est ce que vous faites encore sur ma chaîne Youtube?
OH putain
Gentillesse !
Allez on va dire un mot gentil à chaque mort
c'est mieux
soyeux
Beau
Agréable
AAAAAH !
l'aise
A l'aise
YES !
Putain c'est le paradis là
On est dans une petite ferme
y'a de la verdure
Je vais choper cette cassette je te le dis mec
Nan mais la je vais vraiment l'avoir j'en ai marre !
Casseeeette ?
Putain je vais la choper
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est la maison d'un fan fou ?
Comment avoir des abonnés ? Question Time 1
Pokemon Go la chasse d'un expert
300  000 abonnés
Il a mis des vieilles vidéos c'est rigolo
Ils ont modélisé ma maison
C'est quand je l'appelais dans la première vidéo
C'est mignon !
Oh regardez sur les screen il a mis le pouce bleu à chaque fois
Ben je l'aime hein !
Souviens toi du chemin parcouru jusqu'ici
Aaaaaaaah ok !
Je dois les classer par ordre chronologique
C'est bien joué
Je pense que c'est ça
donc logiquement
la première c'est les 300 000 abonnés
la deuxième c'est question time 1
la troisième c'est les 5 ans
Est-ce-que ça c’était avant Pokémon?
Attends j'ai regardé elle datait de 9 mois et 2 semaines
Pokémon elle datait de juin
Pokémon c'était avant
YOOOUUHH !!
je me connais bien, c'est bien ça c'est bien
ça c'est l'avantage d'avoir un maximum d'égo
du coup tu sais bien ce que t'as fait, quand tu l'as fait
c'est très bien !
putain, faut que je renverse aucune bouteille
Noooooon !
Ho lala mec! Mission commando là
NON !
Tiens tes bières ! Tiens p'tit enculé !
Alcoolique de merde !
c'est dur...
Yes on l'a fait
Oh put***
Mais j'ai pas envie de t'aider depuis tout à l'heure tu me pètes les couilles
Oh stylé !  Une petite scène d'action là
Mais il y a beaucoup de monstres là
Wo wo wooww !!
c'est chaud putain
ouais mais attend !
regarde ça ils viennent tous sur moi !
Oh putain ça va le faire ! Ho ça va le faire
Oh je vais y arriver !
j'ai réussi !!
YES !
ça c'est fait !
Hijo de p*ta
Qui peut me tester maintenant ?!
ouais, ouais, ouais
ouais va te faire enculer ouais
Et ba j'te remercie mon pote
ok
Alors Corentin!
On apprend des choses, hein !!?
hum hum
ok ! alors, mot de passe: AMIXEM
Il faut qu'on trouve le putain d'ordi
aller c'est parti !
Ho putain. Je crois que là on est dans la dernière ligne droite du jeu mec
On va pouvoir retrouver Jumbo
ça va nous faire plaisir
Il m'a fait super peur mec ! Put**n
On dirait...
Hulk qui a fait l'amour à Hellboy
très bizarre...
Ok on est de retour au tout début du game
Faut qu'on trouve l'ordi
LA LAMPE !
Hoo elle est vénère
La lampe elle est carrément fachée !
Put**n mais regarde là quoi
Alors qu'est ce qu'on a dans cette pièce..?!
c'est le bureau
Professeur, docteur Langagne Benjamin ok !
Je peux allumer le PC
Ah ! Il faut le brancher
Hop là !
Ok, mot de passe: Amixem c'est entré
AH !
c'est Jumbo ! Non mais teste pas sur Jumbo !
* musique triste, piano *
putain !
Ouais donc ça c'est le premier chapitre , c'est ce qu'il s'est passé.
Oh putain!
AH !
Ça va péter , il va exploser
OUOOOOH !
Pardon !
Ah c'est bon je suis passé, ok ça s'est refermé.
Oh j'ai eu peur
Ok par là
*cris*
NON !
Ok, il faut juste un truc d'essence et un engrenage
Ok poto t'inquiètes pas je vais trouver le bidon d'essence et l'engrenage
Ah putain elle envoie ses sbires la pu*e
Ouah c'est dur à viser cette merde, saloperie
Saloperie de lampe de merde
Aller , vite un engrenage et un truc d'essence
Yes !
Ca s'est fait
Ok maintenant plus qu'un engrenage et on est bon
Là !
C'est ça je l'ai !
Putain on s'en est sorti sans faire appel à Ben' c'est incroyable
Merde il faut un levier aussi !
Olala ils sont nombreux
Oh je l'ai , je l'ai
Oh !
Yes ! On va pouvoir botter le cul de cette putain de lampe et en finir une bonne fois pour toute
Aaaaaaaaaaah !
Je lui tire dessus !
*musique épique*
Elle est morte !
Aller je te sauve mon pote c'est terminé , fini la souffrance de jouer à ce jeu rageant
Ok on y va
Jumbo !
Jumbo mon chat ! *tic tic*
C'est fini !
Oooh mon dieu !
Et ba ce ne fut pas de tout repos cette histoire hein!
On va pas se mytho j'en ai un peu chié.
On va pas se mytho.
Mec, Benjamin merci beaucoup mon gars.
En fait, je ne sais pas si vous vous en rendez compte mais
faire un jeu comme ça c'est vraiment beaucoup de temps à investir
On va l'appeler on va le remercier, on va lui dire que c'était génial.
On va lui faire une blague, regardez je vais le pranker.
*Ouiiiii*
Ouais vieux je suis encore bloqué...
*T'es bloqué où?*
C'est faux ! J'ai réussi, j'ai terminé!
*Oh oui il a réussi !!*
Et ouais je sais je t'ai pranké en live.
Bon mec bravo c'est ouf
*Beau gosse*
C'est ouf...
Euh vraiment euh.. putain mec... J'ai tourné pendant deux heures parce que je suis nul.
*Ah ba merci, mais deux heures nan ça va, deux heures c'était le temps, le temps prévu à peu près.*
En prenant en compte que je suis très nul
*Oui t'as pas eu besoin de mon aide en plus donc c'était impeccable*
Ouais niquel, ba oui
*Je suis bien content que t'as kiffé en tout cas*
Ba j'ai kiffé, voilà, gros bravo, les gens te disent bravo
Je les entends comme ça à travers la caméra.
Et puis mec, merci beaucoup
Et puis voilà, à je ne sais pas quand pour peut-être un autre jeu, ou j'en sais rien.
*Peut-être, peut-être un chapitre 3, qui sait, on ne sait pas*
Je te fais plein de bisous Ben!
Ba moi aussi, plein de bisous!
Ciao mon gars, bisous
* Ciao peace*
Ciao peace!
Et je ne dis plus peace depuis plusieurs mois ok?!
J'espère que le jeu vous aura fait kiffer aussi, qui vous aura rappelé les délires de 2014-2015
La période des "questions time" etc, c'est vraiment là où il y avait la lampe et Jumbo dans toutes les vidéos, on ne va pas se mentir
Ca a bien changé depuis, mais c'est marrant de voir ce qu'il a fait avec ces persos qu'on avait créé à l'époque
C'est hyper rigolo
Encore bravo Ben, merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo et je vous dit à bientôt dans une prochaine!
*A bientôt!!!*